y'all heard of 50/50 you think you can
handle it yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright I know y'all can't handle this
[ __ ] I know y'all gonna flag this
[ __ ] video like you always do and I
have to call Google and be like hey they
flagged another one yeah my at my fan
base is basically a bunch of [ __ ] oh
this video had blood in it
oh this video had nipples in it boo this
video was a little bit too sexual
ooh he may be swirl excuse me why don't
you just go to the [ __ ] Australia
like the good old days all right what do
you bet you even flag this video already
because you're triggered by my glasses
y'all a bunch of wimps don't like
[ __ ] video all right stop flying the
video I'm sick and tired of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] can you all stop flagging my
[ __ ] videos stop flagging the videos
god damn it I don't make any money if
you flag the video what do you think I'd
do this for free do you think of some
kind of [ __ ] charity do you think I
would do you think I do this for fun do
you think I do YouTube for fun are you
don't lean it for the money [ __ ] you for
even thinking that
alright now I gotta make this video and
he'd be great if you don't [ __ ] flag
it alright
don't flag the video now we're gonna
play 50-50 which basically means it's
gonna be a title alright it's gonna be a
title one of them it's gonna be
something nice like cute kittens alright
number two it's gonna be something nasty
like yo mama's Papa that's right I know
about it
so you would click on the link if we're
gonna get either one of them
50 50 percent chance so if you're not up
for the challenge
H then click the [ __ ] away and don't
flag the video man I should be a rapper
that was pretty good guy kicking
toothpick under toenail or guinea pigs
eating watermelon police beginning pigs
eating watermelon god [ __ ] damn it
why the [ __ ] would you do that you
[ __ ] idiot what did you think what
did you think what's gonna happen you're
[ __ ] him [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you you [ __ ] idiot
goddamn a god damnit
alright we weren't lucky on that one
fifty-fifty Rob Ryan covering his wife
toes with barbecue sauce where the [ __ ]
is Rob Ryan like why do they expect me
to know who Rob Ryan is he's beautiful
though why didn't they not holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] put this guy on a L'Oreal
commercial right [ __ ] now or Frank
and foot one week after gnarly moco
motorcycle accident I feel like these
are both failures what the [ __ ] it's
okay you can flank the video you know
what you can flag the video interesting
water slugs the wrong way to feed lions
oh oh I ain't scared
mm [ __ ] me here we go
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] man
is he getting eaten lab helps boy with
his bag coming home from school all
right
bad landing leads to leg bending the
wrong way come on man don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] man don't be a goddamn you you
with me or not oh my god yes look at
that he comes to get his boy but he got
his bag even that is the cutest thing oh
well that is amazing science have really
brought us far
elephants drinking out of a pool on a
terrace sounds lovely
or cutting open a shark and finding a
half-eaten human arm what the actual
[ __ ] is that a thing oh thank god this
is not a shark oh oh the sweet
satisfaction is just so good man hey
elephants dude what's happening what is
that guy Liv [ __ ] jungle is this guy
torsion a baby in martial arts pose and
a child with fetal sherab I don't know
what that is
[ __ ] you what is wrong with you what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you what the [ __ ] is wrong
I'm asking you [ __ ] you
why am i saying [ __ ] you [ __ ] you read
it what the [ __ ] who [ __ ] post that
[ __ ] this is playing with your emotions
it's like a [ __ ] roller coaster
except you feel like [ __ ] regardless god
damn it you know what let's cheer up a
little bit let's cheer up a little bit
yes
all right we're gonna get adorable
Bevers we're gonna get adorable Bevers
or extremely graphic no way no I can't a
tiger has a hamster pen strippers
accidentally spray Tyria
onto clients mouth I kinda want to see
both
come on
you're still in there to win it
yet you're still here we have Anna
Kournikova dancing in a yacht or biker
gets crushed by semi-truck
there is a god crazy guy playing guitar
on train or woman shoves fisher-price
Jesus we keep winning
I'm on a roll baby I'm on a [ __ ] roll
now let's finish this with a perfectly
grilled bratwurst god damn it's the
worst thing that could happen
geez says well you got a flayed foot god
[ __ ] alright well this has been fun
let me know if you want more of these
type of videos if you do go ahead and
leave it like thank you for not flagging
this video and thank you for being in
balance with me that's that's right
that's what you are and as always stay
awesome browse the Donkey Kong
soundtrack [ __ ] yeah the good Zilla
dance I love this [ __ ] [ __ ] lip for
the gorilla desk